I stayed tight for a very long time we
started spending money the year after
the 17 million in profit and when I say
spending money I mean increasing our
living expenses to maybe I don't know 40
Grand a month and that may sound like a
lot but we were taking home 1 and a half
million a month you know by percentage
it wasn't a huge amount and that was
because I talked to some wealthier
friends who were like dude you can chill
like you can get double meet at Chipotle
if you want to you know you can get guac
yeah I did this brief period where like
I bought a Bentley I ended up returning
it 6 months later I got to learn quickly
that's not something that I get a lot of
you know joy out of on the flip side I
have an incredibly expensive commercial
gym setup that's what I actually jam on
and enjoy a lot